yeah good hello ladies and gentlemen
your mama regardless i would like to be
the very warm welcome to the President
of the United States Barack Obama very
warm welcome ed to Berlin it's his first
visit to Berlin as president of the
United States certainly not his first
visit to Germany we have had on numerous
occasions the opportunity to talk we
have established ties of friendship
based on trust and I would like to thank
you for this our cooperation is based on
ties of friendship that have lasted for
many many decades between the Fed
republic of germany and the united
states and this is such a very good
relationship because it is based on
shared values when the present addresses
and the crowd in front of the
Brandenburg Gate it will be a president
who can do this in front of a gate that
is open another presence had to remind
us all of the wall needed to be torn
down and the wall is down and this is
what we owe to our American partners and
friends but we also see that the world
is changing and indeed changing at a
very rapid pace so new challenges come
to the fore and we wanted to tackle them
with resolve and we want to tackle them
together what looms most prominently on
agenda here in Germany but also know
Europe and I trust in the United States
and could be a very valuable amis of the
world that free trade agreement I am
very glad that we were able to conclude
the negotiations leading up to the
mandate we will throw our effort behind
this fully else quality because we think
that economies on both sides of the
Atlantic why very much benefit from that
it's going to be a win-win situation and
it also is an eloquent testimony to this
globalized world where we can
work better together both politically
and economically so this is why I think
this is in a very very important free
trade agreement and essay this on behalf
of the federal government as a whole we
talked about questions on the Internet
in the context of prison we talked at
great length about the new possibilities
and about also the new threats that the
internet news opens up to all of us the
internet is new territory uncharted
territory all of us and it also enables
our enemies it enables enemies our free
liberal order to use it to abuse it to
bring a threat to all of us to threaten
our way of life and this is why we value
cooperation with the United States on
questions of security I also outlined
however that although we do see the need
for garnering information and there
needs to be due diligence also as
regards e proportionality a free liberal
democracies live of people are having a
feeling of security and this is why an
equitable balance needs to be struck
there needs to be proportionality and
that is something that we agreed on to
have a free exchange of views on between
our staff but also the staff of the Home
Secretary and in the states and also the
Minister of Interior here in Germany and
this is going to be an ongoing dialogue
we talked about a number of foreign
policy issues we are both of us engaged
in Afghanistan a new process has been
initiated their of a transition of
responsibility this is a process that we
are going to tackle together just as we
tackled the greater military challenges
at the past together building up the
security forces in Afghanistan together
we will stand together with the United
States and solve outstanding problems
that are very difficult indeed still we
also address Iran we address the Middle
East situation as regards the peace
process in the Middle East I
think that the initiative of secretary
Kerry offers a very good opportunity to
revive revitalize a peace talks the
Union in the region needs peace the
partners ought to take up the offer that
is on the table because it is urgently
necessary to bring about negotiations
and we will continue also to work on
Iran on the nuclear program of Iran that
is also something that we agreed on we
had very good talks we had as usual very
open and can you talk so yet again a
very woman